THAT BLM PROTESTERS HAVE BEEN
USING THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS.
JOHN?
>> John: THAT RALLY EXPECTED
TO GET UNDERWAY VERY SHORTLY.
I KNOW YOU WILL BE FOLLOWING UP
FOR US AND WE WILL CHECK BACK IN
WITH YOU LATER THIS MORNING.
>> Sandra: MORE ON ALL THIS,
THE GUN VIOLENCE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WITH THE LOUISIANA
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY, A MEMBER
OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
IT’S HEARTBREAKING TO SEE IT’S
HAPPENING IN OUR MAJOR AMERICAN
CITIES AND IT STILL SEEMS TO BE
ON THE RISE.
WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT IT,
SENATOR?
>> OUR MAYORS ARE OBVIOUSLY NOT
DOING ENOUGH.
THERE ARE THREE THINGS THEY
OUGHT TO DO IMMEDIATELY IN MY
JUDGMENT.
NUMBER ONE, DON’T DEFUND THE
POLICE.
NUMBER TWO, I LOVE SOCIAL
WORKERS BUT DON’T SEND A SOCIAL
WORKER TO DO THE COPS JOB.
NUMBER THREE,
NUMBER THREE, CALL
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG AND RUDY
GIULIANI AND ASKED US TO FORM TO
FORMER MAYORS HOW THEY GOT
CONTROL OF THE VIOLENCE IN
NEW YORK CITY.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THEY
IMPLEMENTED STOP QUESTION AND
FRISK.
THEY USED IT AS IT SHOULD BE
USED IN A RACIALLY NEUTRAL
MANNER.
IT’S PERFECTLY CONSTITUTIONAL,
LOOK AT THE 1968 OPINION, TERRY
V OHIO WRITTEN BY ALL PEOPLE
CHIEF JUSTICE WARREN, ONE OF THE
MOST HONORABLE PEOPLE HE HAD ON
THE SUPREME COURT.
>> Sandra: THIS PRESIDENT HAS
SAID THOUGH IF THE MAYORS DON’T
STEP IN AND DON’T DO SOMETHING
TO STOP THIS THAT HE WILL OFFER
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE, FEDERAL HELP
WILL BE OFFERED TO STEP IN.
DO YOU SUPPORT THAT AND AT WHAT
LEVEL SHOULD THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STEPPED IN TO STOP
VIOLENCE?
>> WHILE I HAVEN’T TALKED TO THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT IT BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS HE HAS OFFERED
MANY OF OUR MAYORS FEDERAL HELP
AND MOST IF NOT ALL OF THEM HAVE
SAID NO.
AND WE ARE REAPING THE
CONSEQUENCES RIGHT NOW.
A CIVILIZATION TO BE CIVILIZED
HAS TO HAVE RULES.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY TO
ENFORCE THOSE RULES AND THAT’S A
RULE OF OUR COPS.
SO MANY OF THESE MAYORS THINK
THAT COPS ARE GUILTY UNTIL
PROVEN INNOCENT.
>> Sandra: I WANT TO GO TO THE
MESSAGING THAT WE SAW FROM THE
PRESIDENT YESTERDAY, AND THIS IS
JOE BIDEN SPEAKING IN DELAWARE.
THE PRESIDENT SPEAKING IN THE
ROSE GARDEN.
THE BACKWARD LOOKING POLICIES
THAT WILL HARM THE ENVIRONMENT,
AND THERE’S PROBABLY NEVER BEEN
A KEY TIME THAT THE CANDIDATES
HAVE SO DIFFERENT.
>> Sandra: IT’S NOT A CAMPAIGN
STYLE SPEECH WHICH WASN’T
EXACTLY WHAT WAS PROMISED BUT
MEANWHILE YOU HAVE POLLS
INDICATING THAT JOE BIDEN IS
LEAVING.
HE’S A TRUMP SUPPORTER
CANDIDATE.
SO WHAT DOES THAT SAY ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S REELECTION
CHANCES?
>> WHILE I CAN TELL YOU WHY I’M
NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE’S A PROPONENT OF THE "I
DESERVE, YOU OWE ME" MENTALITY.
I BELIEVE IN MORE FREE STUFF.
I THINK THE VICE PRESIDENT
THINKS THAT THE WAY THEY HANDLED
CHINA, AND A CUP OF COCOA.
AND WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE I
THINK THEY WILL SEE THEY TOOK A
HIRED LEFT AND KEPT DRIVING.
THERE WAS A ROUNDTABLE
DISCUSSION, THEY BELIEVE THAT
LOUISIANA PUBLIC SCHOOL SHOULD
OPEN EVEN IF CDC GUIDANCE CAN BE
FOLLOWED.
>> LATER THIS WEEK WE ANTICIPATE
THAT DR. REDFIELD AND THE TEAM
AT CDC WILL ISSUE ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE AND WE DON’T WANT THAT
TO BE THE REASON THAT PEOPLE
DON’T OPEN THEIR SCHOOLS.
>> Sandra: IT’S ALMOST
DIFFICULT TO FIND A GUIDANCE AND
IT’S OPEN ANYWAY.
DO YOU SUPPORT THAT MESSAGE?
>> FIRST, WE WERE AT LSU WHERE
YOU WERE A SCHOLAR ATHLETE, I
USED TO TEACH THERE.
HERE’S WHAT I HEARD THE
VICE PRESIDENT SAY.
HE SAID THE CDC GUIDELINES OR
GUIDELINES, EDUCATIONS AND LOCAL
DECISION.
USE YOUR OWN GOOD JUDGMENT.
HERE’S WHAT I ALSO HEARD HIM SAY
SAY.
FOR WHATEVER REASON, AND THIS IS
A GOOD THING, OUR KIDS DON’T
SEEM TO BE AS SUSCEPTIBLE OR AT
LEAST GET NEARLY AS SICK AS
ADULTS DO FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
I THINK WE’VE HAD 30 DEATHS KIDS
UNDER 15 WHICH IS 32 MANY, OF
COURSE.
I THINK THAT KEEPING THE SCHOOLS
CLOSED WILL DO FAR MORE HARM TO
OUR KIDS THAN THE BRUNT OF OUR
SUMMER CAMP.
NOW.
IT IS UP TO THE PARENTS, I
BELIEVE PARENTS OFTEN ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR KIDS.
IF YOU WON’T DON’T WANT TO SEND
YOUR KID BACK TO SCHOOL THEN
DON’T.
IF YOU ARE A TEACHER, AND YOU
DON’T WANT TO GO BACK, THEN
DON’T.
THAT’S BETWEEN HIM AND THE
SCHOOL BOARD.
BUT I THINK FOR MANY OF OUR
CHILDREN IN AMERICA, SCHOOL IS
THE MOST STABLE THING IN THEIR
LIVES.
IT’S MORE THAN JUST EDUCATION.
ITS HEALTH CARE, MENTAL HEALTH
AND COUNSELING AND WE NEED TO
GET THEM OPEN.
I’VE WATCHED DOZENS OF OTHER
COUNTRIES DO IT, EVEN VIETNAM,
FOR GOD’S SAKES, HAS OPENED UP
THEIR SCHOOLS.
IF THEY CAN DO IT SAFELY, WE
CAN, TOO.
I DO THINK IT HAS ALSO BEEN
POLITICIZED, SANDRA.
>> Sandra: ABSOLUTELY.
>> THERE ARE SOME POLITICIANS IN
WASHINGTON, NOT ALL, I DON’T
WANT TO PAINT WITH TOO BROAD OF
A BRUSH, BUT I THINK THEY LIKE
THE POLITICAL CHAOS OF HAVING
OUR SCHOOLS CLOSED.
THEY THINK IT WILL HELP THEM IN
NOVEMBER.
I JUST THINK WE OUGHT TO THINK
ABOUT THE NEXT GENERATION OUT
THE ELECTION.
>> Sandra: DEMOCRATS ARE
PUSHING BACK ON THAT MESSAGE
VERY HARD, THAT THEIR PRIORITY
AS THE CHILDREN AND THE SAFETY
OF THE CHILDREN SO THAT THE
DEBATE THAT IS FIRING UP AS
WELL.
BUT THERE SEEMS TO BE MIXED
MESSAGING EVEN INSIDE OF THE
WHITE HOUSE WHEN IT COMES TO ALL
OF THIS.
NOW, YOU HAVE THIS NEW OP-ED IN
THE USA TODAY PENNED BY PETER
NAVARRO, AND ECONOMIC ADVISOR TO
THE PRESIDENT, OR HE’S
ESSENTIALLY MAKING THE CASE THAT
DR. FAUCI IS WRONG.
HERE’S A PIECE OF IT.
ANTHONY FAUCI HAS BEEN WRONG
ABOUT EVERYTHING I’VE INTERACTED
WITH HIM ON.
HE HAS GOOD BEDSIDE MANNER WITH
THE PUBLIC BUT HE’S BEEN WRONG
ABOUT EVERYTHING I’VE INTERACTED
WITH HIM ON.
SO WHEN YOU ASK ME IF I LISTEN
TO DR. FAUCI’S ADVICE, MY ANSWER
IS ONLY WITH SKEPTICISM AND
CAUTION.
I WILL QUICKLY POINT OUT THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS REACTED TO
THIS, DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS, SAID THIS DID
NOT GO THROUGH NORMAL
WHITE HOUSE CLEARANCE PROCESSES
AND IT IS THE OPINION OF PETER
NAVARRO ALONE, THE PRESIDENT
VALUES EXPERTISE OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS ADVISING HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT SENATOR KENNEDY, DOES IT
HELP TO HAVE THIS MIXED
MESSAGING AND HAVE SOMEONE ON
THE PRESIDENT’S TEAM PUBLICLY
ATTACKING THE LEAD INFECTIOUS
DISEASE EXPERT ADVISING THE
PRESIDENT?
>> I KNOW BOTH MR. NAVARRO AND
DR. FAUCI.
I LIKE THEM BOTH AND I RESPECT
THEM BOTH, I TRUST DR. FAUCI.
BUT I DON’T THINK IT’S A
NEWS FLASH THAT MR. NAVARRO AND
DR. FAUCI HAVE NOT GOTTEN ALONG
FROM DAY NUMBER ONE.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
THEY TIED UP.
I DON’T KNOW WHY PETER WROTE THE
COLUMN, IT IS WHAT IT ISN’T HE’S
ENTITLED TO HIS OPINION.
THIS IS AMERICA, OR AT LEAST FOR
NOW WE ARE ENTITLED TO OUR
OPINION.
I WOULD HAVE PREFERRED IT THAT
HE NOT WRITE IT.
I WAS WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT,
DR. BIRX YESTERDAY AND THE
ADMIRAL AND EVERYONE IS ON THE
SAME PAGE.
I KNOW THE VICE PRESIDENT THINKS
THE WORLD OF DR. FAUCI.
I DO.
IS HE RIGHT 100% OF THE TIME,
NO.
NONE OF US ARE, WE ARE LEARNING
EVERY DAY ABOUT THIS VIRUS.
>> Sandra: ALL RIGHT,